Mr. V:
There are plenty of pretty voices
with nothing to say.
Mr. V:
Do you have something to say?
Ruby:
♪♪ Oh, oh sometimes, I get a
good feeling, yeah... ♪♪
♪♪ YEAAAAH! ♪♪
♪♪ I get a feeling that I never,
never, never, never had before ♪♪
Mr. V:
You're the girl with the deaf
family?
♪♪ YEAAAH! ♪♪
Ruby:
Yeah.
♪♪ I just wanna tell you right
now ♪♪
And you sing? Interesting.
♪♪
♪♪ Something's got a hold on me,
yeah ♪♪
What are you doing next year?
Working with my family.
♪♪ Let me tell you now ♪♪
♪♪ I've got a feeling ♪♪
♪♪ I feel so strange ♪♪
♪♪ Everything about me ♪♪
♪♪ Seems to have changed ♪♪
♪♪
I've been coaching for Berklee
College of Music.
Mr. V:
I can help you get a
scholarship.
♪♪ Got ahold of me and won't let
go ♪♪
♪♪ I said oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! ♪♪
♪♪ Oh! Oh! OH! ♪♪
♪♪
Ruby:
I wanna do this.
♪♪
Mr. V:
There are plenty of pretty
voices with nothing to say.
♪♪
Mr. V:
Do you have something to say?
♪♪
(Screams)
You will be required to have a
hearing individual on board at
all times.
♪♪
I can't stay with you for the
rest of my life.
(Screams)
♪♪
I've never done anything without
my family before.
♪♪
♪♪ You're all, all that I
need... ♪♪
♪♪
♪♪ ...to get by ♪♪